arrests of two black men at a
Philadelphia Starbucks in April raised a
lot of questions about how companies
train their employees to avoid racial
bias a recent Harvard Business Review
study found discrimination is prevalent
in the customer service industry the
study discovered hotel employees gave a
20% more restaurant recommendations to
white people than to black or Asian
people it also says race affects
employees politeness WCBS anchor and CBS
News contributor me Maurice Dubois his
name is here to show us how a chain of
restaurants in the Washington DC area is
tackling this issue this is very
interesting to a lot of people Maurice
good morning good morning to you thank
you all and good morning everyone
Busboys and poets is a restaurant and
bookstore chain that employs about 650
people across six locations in
Washington for the past 13 years
restaurateur Andy Shallal has been
conducting his unique brand of racial
bias training for his employees we
recently attended a training session
with a group of 10 Millennials we met in
a room after named after Langston Hughes
the renowned poet who was once a busboy
can you be color blind in America no
being color blind is like completely
rejecting somebodies culture and who
they are how they are this is kind of my
headquarters race has perplexed artists
turn restaurant tour Andy Shallal since
he first came to America in 1966 as a 10
year old Iraqi refugee my family lived
in Virginia and back then I was
introduced to race in America it hits
you right in the face absolutely because
I was a small boy with an afro and
darker skin sometimes thought I was
black some people thought of his wife
some people thought I was who knows
what does the kid make of that it's
confusing because I didn't know anything
about race
chilao set out to create a community
where people of different cultures and
races could interact and shares his
vision with employees every couple of
weeks at an Tobias trainings a lot of
white people for instance I always hear
them say that I'm colorblind like that's
the ultimate the ultimate space to be in
which means that you don't see color and
therefore you don't have any racism or
prejudice in your bones I'm saying your
color mine is like you don't really see
me it's not to be colorblind your goal
should be more to see me see my culture
and appreciate that
how does race impact the way you serve
for me I'm not gonna say race doesn't
exist it does but I bring my same
attitude to any table that I go to when
let's say a host at the front door it's
a Saturday morning do we just open the
door let's say the entire space is open
at that moment in time so the hostess
wants to see people according to
sections so the black couple walks in
through the door they walk through an
entire empty restaurant and they get
seated in that back corner what is the
black couple thinking put them in the
back why why you sitting in the back and
this server had gotten my first scene
and he had got any teams they just set
them randomly at the next table but what
you have to do is explain you have to
keep the lines of communication open
because if you don't then people will
know now let me ask you this let me go
back to my example what if a white
couple walks in and they get seated in
that back corner what's the right couple
thinking they got the whole room to
ourselves or something yeah
Oh depends what the hostess looks like
everyone reads the book by its cover no
matter what you think I was having this
conversation with the gentleman the
other day in the uber riot the way to
work me say why is being black different
than being any other race or any other
color
was he black or was he he was black and
I was like because they can see us
coming physically you can see us comment
and you can make your perception from
there
what about main takeaways here how you
gonna change the way you do your job to
me this discussion is a mindfulness
exercise it's an invitation to be
deliberate and to not sink into the
biases that I have built up over many
years and it's a reminder to practice
compassion what are gonna do the next
time you run into an ugly situation my
first thing is always to question
someone because to question someone is
to take that next step or open that door
first be aware that there is a bias in
order to like you know fix it and they
probably didn't even know they were
knowing you know anybody think well this
is a nice discussion but people the
people are gonna be who they are and
nothing's gonna change I think that when
you were hired here you've already
demonstrated that your mind is open
enough to accept other people's
experiences and learn about them and
about yourself so I think what I'm here
to say is that the people who need to
hear this aren't here right now I do
think that we need to bring this
conversation to a wider audience like we
could all have these ideas but
go out and physically start the
conversation that's the hardest thing to
do is the word as simple as respect is
that all it is yeah respect other
people's I think the biggest biggest
problem at least in America when it
comes to race relation is like
recognizing just like where we are as a
person and as a people to figure out
exactly how we fix the problem now Jamal
acknowledges these conversations are
just the first step not the solution
necessarily sure Lyle has a history of
being politically active he ran for
mayor of Washington and 2014 he now sees
these training sessions as a way of
creating change in his small corner of
the world it's so interesting I love the
example about being seated in a
restaurant a black couple would think
why are we back here when there's all
those empty tables no white couple maybe
great we have it all to ourselves that
is so true it's all about perception
right in what was really interesting to
me is this is a group of Millennials
this session went on for a whole
afternoon yeah nobody looked at their
phones everyone wanted to talk and be
heard on this topic so it seems to be a
real thirst I think of it mindfulness
it's not very very very nice Maurice
nicely done nice to see you thank you
thank you